why is testosterone dropping so
aggressively in America you got a bunch
of guys that are depressed that don't
have energy that can't focus they can't
concentrate they're gaining weight
faster their libido's gone and when you
think about the downstream effects of
all those things it really messes with
our psyche the average testosterone
level has gone down by 26 over the past
three decades not just in the U.S
globally I don't want to have this
conversation it scares the [ __ ] out
because everyone's clear this seems like
a big problem no one's really talking
about 40 of men 40 over 35 suffer from
hormonal imbalances and low testosterone
and no one's willing to talk about it
why won't they talk about it all right
guys bang bang got sod here with me uh I
thought a great place to start would be
the problem testosterone levels in
America are plummeting I've seen all
kinds of crazy stats it's like 50 less
testosterone every 20 years or whatever
it ends up being why is testosterone
dropping so aggressively in America
all right so it's not a straightforward
answer and honestly it's going to sound
a little bit conservatorial right the
reality is that the scientific Community
is actually all now believing this is
the real reason so when you look at all
the Plastics the fertilizers the folates
the pcbs and our food and our drinking
water deodorants we use shampoos we put
on our head for a man they get into our
bodies and they resemble these
estrogenic compounds now the way our
body works is these estrogenic compounds
they kind of hit this pituitary gland in
our head which is like a we'll call it
like a thermostat for our hormones and
it says there's too much estrogen in our
body and that tells our bodies to
actually stop normal or what we call
endogenous testosterone production okay
so let's go to science class I'm an
idiot you're an expert at this whether
you want to admit it or not
um when I think of testosterone estrogen
is the antithesis opposite yes opposite
all right what is the relationship so
when you say there's too much uh
estrogen the body believes there's too
much estrogen why is it stopping
testosterone production wonderful
question and actually most people never
ask that they just take it at face value
because they're they want to seem smart
I just know
idiots are strong word yeah uh I'm on
your podcast and I'm excited it's all
hell to be here let's get that straight
so here's what ends up happening when
you have testosterone produced in your
body it we'll call it converts into two
things one thing it converts into is to
DHT most people know DHT is that little
molecule that attaches onto your hair
follicles it makes you go bald if you're
susceptible to male pattern baldness the
other thing is it trans converts into
estrogen so if your body thinks there's
too much estrogen or so let me say that
differently if your mind thinks there's
too much estrogen in your body it's
going to say well I know I get estrogen
because I take testosterone and convert
it so let me stop producing as much
testosterone in my body interesting so
if it stops the testosterone production
is a silver lining that people who would
be prone to losing their hair won't lose
their hair as fast
you are that is a a very nice way to
look at the problem and I think that the
way to look at it is you may have some
guys that are not losing their hair as
fast but on the flip side you got a
bunch of guys that are depressed that
don't have energy that can't focus they
can't concentrate they're gaining weight
faster their libido's gone and when you
think about the downstream effects of
all those things it really messes with
our psyche right because so much of our
personality is about providing and being
there and being masculine so
testosterone it basically provides all
the things you just said Focus energy uh
libido like all these different things
when somebody goes and gets their
testosterone tested what is the like
average male in America's testosterone
level today
and was it twice as high 20 years ago 10
years ago five years ago like how fast
is the problem exasperating so the way
to look at it so it's it's a very
difficult answer for me to tell you what
is the average testosterone level in a
for a man in America
let's say that the way to look at
testosterone is there's usually what
I'll call there's a range the top of
that range is 900 nanograms per
deciliter at the bottom of that range is
300 nanograms per deciliter and so long
as you're somewhere in there most people
say that you're okay the reality though
is you should be higher if you're
younger and you're it should be lower if
you're older and most Physicians
generally say if you're in there I don't
care if you're 33 years old and you have
a 300 nanograms per deciliter
testosterone level you're fine when the
realities should probably be more like
700 but that being said because I know
that I'm getting a little bit deep here
the average testosterone level has gone
down by 26 percent over the past three
decades not just in the U.S globally now
here's another number that's crazy over
the past three decades sperm count has
gone down by 50 50. I mean those are
massive numbers those are very very big
numbers
um relationship between testosterone and
sperm count is
also a little bit more nuanced but
generally this is the way to think about
it if you have the right testosterone
level not an elevated testosterone level
the right testosterone level for your
body testosterone goes into your testes
and tells these things called your
sertoli cells to produce more sperm so
generally if you have enough
testosterone you produce more sperm if
your testosterone is too low you may not
produce enough sperm
if your testosterone is too high do you
not produce enough or do you produce too
much also a little bit of a nuanced
answer if you were using testosterone
from an exogenous means meaningless
shooting nailed it yeah shooting no EXO
yeah I used Google this morning can we
get this man a PhD
what basically ends up happening is your
body says oh my God there's too much
testosterone on my body let me also shut
down normal production and so then you
start stop producing as much sperm so
very often when guys go on testosterone
for a prolonged period of time their
sperm counts are reduced I'm actually
one of those individuals you know how
much sperm I have that's a weird
question
that before okay how much zero zero and
I'd also like you to know this too in
your office over there yeah I have
special medication that I inject to
improve my sperm really I dead serious
am I going there trying to have a baby
all right so hold on a second explain
why you don't have any sperm okay so let
me I'm actually a little bit deep here
okay just so I can make sure I draw the
full loop so what ends up happening is
you have this pituitary gland in your
head your pituitary gland sends this
hormone called LH also known as
luteinizing hormone down to your testes
and you have these cells in your testes
called these latex cells latex cells
they see the LH and they go guess what
produce as much testosterone as you can
okay so mine sends a signal to your
balls yes and is like produce sperm boom
okay no produce testosterone okay
produce testosterone the testosterone
tells another set of cells to produce
sperm okay but if I give your body too
much testosterone from the outside that
thermostat in your brain goes whoa way
too much testosterone and the signal to
my balls to produce testosterone which
then produces sperm that basically goes
away okay that makes sense so I take
testosterone because I've been through
this problem that's why I was inspired
to start the company and because of that
my sperm count is literally zero and so
now I take another medication that
basically tells my brain to produce more
LH to tell my balls produce more sperm
yes okay so what's interesting to me
about the human body
um which is like we're [ __ ] awesome
right is that our bodies are trying to
regulate between these things it doesn't
want too much doesn't want too little
it's kind of just right and that is true
of testosterone that's true of estrogen
that's true of LH or like all these
different things it's trying to figure
out like stay Within These uh kind of
extreme bands or bands ever
and one of the things that I've read
about spent a lot of time with the folks
already asleep and they've taught me
about is that like sleep is almost a
period where the body like kind of
re-regulates and tries to get into uh
what I would consider the normal ranges
let's start there as like that's natural
right what's going on when you're
sleeping that's helping to regulate some
of these hormones and like why is it
that if I don't sleep that much I'm like
a [ __ ] frantic mess and like
everyone's like holy [ __ ] my life sucks
if you sleep a ton you wake up you're
just like I am Zen really like life is
good like what's going on with the sleep
stuff
also deep question right so that the
easiest way to say it is when you sleep
for a prolonged period of time your body
is able to send will actually say go
through a series of different processes
where it's cleaning itself out both in
its brain and your body and then your
body is basically able to regulate
itself right so if you think about it
when we wake up there's this part of
ourselves that's having the conversation
that's completely with the conversation
then there's another part of our body
that's saying Hey I want your heart to
be right I want to make sure that uh all
these different processes in your bodies
are occurring without you ever knowing
about it and the reality is when you
don't sleep for a prolonged period of
time your body doesn't give the other
part of yourself the ability to
basically say I want you to heal and I
want you to regenerate and the reality
is that when you think about why
testosterone levels are low it's a
little bit more multifaceted than just
we'll call it phthalates and pcbs you
also look at people are sleeping less
they're looking at their phones right
before they go to sleep they're
consuming a ton a blue light that messes
with your REM sleep that messes with
your deep sleep that means your body
doesn't have the chance to go and kind
of like re-engineer itself while you're
sleeping anymore right literally I am
right I've got an aura ring I've got uh
one of these wonderful whoop bands I
don't know if you know Mateo down here
in Miami I've got an eight-sleep
mattress I am constantly thinking about
how to make myself sleep as good as I
possibly can because arguably all this
other stuff we're doing it's actually
literally useless if you don't do two
three things you don't sleep better you
don't drink enough water sounds silly
and the other thing is if you just don't
reduce the stress in your life yeah how
much water do you drink a day two liters
okay I drink I drink two of these I
literally get up in the morning this is
going to sound crazy I will chug one of
these in the morning first thing that's
one liter okay now this is actually a
liter and a half so when you chug a
leader let's say yeah or a liter and a
half uh you mentioned Plastics earlier I
have a plastic water bottle right here
I feel like every time I drink I don't
know
75 of the time maybe not every time but
like 75 of the time it's like out of a
plastic water bottle should I stop doing
that you should stop doing that and you
should you're doing it I am traveling
and it's because that my my my glass
water bottle is on my bed because
there's a very high probability if I
brought it because like most men I would
lose it
all right so like you'll do it when you
need to but the ideal scenario is that
you don't actually drink out of the
plastic bottles as much as possible yep
or microwave things out of plastic
containers that's another big one okay
what is that like literally if I just
have a plastic container and I put it in
the microwave that's bad yep why same
exact thing Plastics are heating up
they're getting into your food right
like here's the rally right I do a lot
of meal prep because I like eating very
healthy okay at first I used to have
we'll call it six different meals over
the course of the day putting these
little plastic trays trays could get
them off Amazon maybe they're like a
quarter a piece cheapest plastic in the
world I throw them in the microwave for
two minutes all of a sudden they're
heating up and all that plastic is in my
food that's not good no it's horrible
okay so when you measure your
testosterone pre starting a testosterone
optimization companies how it started
and then we'll talk about kind of how
you guys have evolved over time
what was like what were you seeing as
like hey this is a problem
so
it's scary right so the first thing that
started happening yeah I don't want to
have this conversation this scares the
[ __ ] out because everyone's clear like
the reason I want to talk to you is like
I'm like this seems like a big problem
no one's really talking about it we'll
we'll talk about why it's so stigmatized
we'll talk about why it's so damaging to
a guy and interestingly you're 34 almost
35 years old and my problems started
right when I was 35. perfect I can't
wait well no the best thing is I didn't
have a solution yeah you have a solution
Yeah okay or even better yet you know
that you know the company yes so the
first thing that started happening right
and let me give you this background okay
I'm insanely healthy I've always been
insanely healthy I've worked out five
days six days a week for the past 25
years of my life I eat perfectly I
meditate twice a day literally in my
office like years here infrared sauna
hyperbaric oxygen chamber cold plunge
I'm gonna go cold plunge with a guy
after this that sounds weird
[Laughter]
and it's informative but like you're
even doing this when you're traveling so
obviously it's important to you well you
know what's interesting I'm going to
meet with a friend that's been very
successful entrepreneur I'm also raising
Capital so we're gonna go have that
conversation and rather than go have
drinks and go to like a traditional
restaurant let's go hit a sauna let's go
cold plunge let's go do these new
protocols that are in place that people
have been doing and so then it's now
let's have a conversation about health
and wellness you live that life like I
said I just turned 40. I feel like I'm
in my 20s I work out like I'm in my 20s
and frankly like that's the life I want
to continue living getting back to your
point though
your point was when you think about your
testosterone levels thank you like where
were you when so like I have to solve
this problem
first thing is when I turned 35 all of a
sudden I could start to feel my energy
levels starting to fade a little bit I
wasn't getting up popping up at six
o'clock in the morning wanting to run to
the gym all of a sudden right around
noon I started to probably sit down lay
down maybe I napped a couple times by
six o'clock I was completely burnt out
which is the opposite of my personality
then all of a sudden I noticed my mental
acuity start to slow down right I could
do very complex mathematical equations
in my head always have been able to do
always had a perfect recall of things
and all of a sudden I was struggling to
think about like man what's that thing
from yesterday and that guy's name and
that happened then I started to gain
weight right and we hate it when it
happens but you get those wonderful love
handles some people call them muffin
tops and no matter what I did wouldn't
go away
then the straw that really broke the
camel's back libido was gone so then I
started having conversations with my
girl where it sounds like hey baby it's
not you it's really me and then it's
like no you're cheating on me I was like
I swear to you there's no cheating I
love you I'm gonna marry you but there's
something else listen I have focus on I
have energy and now you're mad at me
which let's be honest that's worse than
moths because when your girl is mad at
you yes the World falls apart
now the scary thing though is right
my father started suffering from chronic
conditions right around the same time
and that was the beginning of type 2
diabetes type 1 diabetes kidney disease
multiple strokes and so I had this in
the back of my head which is I'd finally
just sold a company right I thought I
should have been on top of the world and
now all of a sudden I'm like holy crap
my body's starting to fall apart and
then you start thinking to yourself is
this the beginning of the end am I less
of a man will I be able to take care of
my family will I be able to accomplish
all the things I want and that seed of
doubt that seed of Doubt is What's So
Scary because it turned into like the
self-defeating negative feedback cycle
that no one wants in their life because
then you just constantly sit there and
it gnaws at you over and over
so I go to my primary care doctor who's
a concierge level doc I say hey look
something's really wrong with me
he has me go do my blood he brings me
back and this [ __ ] story can I
say that yeah you can say whatever you
want this [ __ ] says
you know it's odd you were a shining
example of Health you look great looks
like you take care of yourself but you
know Middle Eastern men they tend to age
a little bit faster so this is probably
that's the beginning of old age and
because you're so obsessive I think you
have some Millennial existential angst
and maybe I should give you an SSRI and
you should go see a therapist and I was
like are you [ __ ] crazy that was
literally I was like that's that is what
top Quality Healthcare in this country
looks like absolutely not
and that's where like this journey began
man I started seeing doctor after doctor
I saw about a dozen doctors over six
months and I finally met a group of
hormone optimization regenerative
Physicians and they look at looked at
the same blood work and they were like
oh my God at the testosterone levels of
an 80 year old man so what all right so
these folks uh you said a hormone
optimization regenerative physician
physician all right what do they do
that sounds like some [ __ ] I need what
are those guys they help you live
forever perfect perfect uh
when they're looking at the blood work
are they looking at the same things like
they're putting just as much importance
on the same things they just know what
to do with it that maybe a regular
doctor doesn't so going back to that
comment about the range right
most Physicians God bless all of them
because they've saved so many lives when
they go to medical school they're very
often just said taught if it's within
range which comes back from the lab
patient's fine got it when the reality
though is I had a 280 nanograms per
deciliter that's below the 300 bottom of
the range below the 300 bottom of the
lanes but the lab that that physician
went to had their range at 180. ah so
you're within the range of some random
lab but maybe not in the range of what a
young person should have had yep and let
me complicate this every lab uses a
different analyzer and every analyzer
has its own range even Lab Core uses
different analyzers and they have
different ranges based upon which lab
you go to and the reality is that
there's so much Nuance within that range
and for a 35 year old man going back to
the comment I made I should have had a
700 or a 750 when the realities I was
sitting at 280 and at one point it
actually went even lower than that and
so they looked at it and they've said
very easily understand what's happening
here okay
problem alarm goes off they're like yo
boom this shit's bad
what do they tell you to do so before
you go on your own Journey what do they
tell you you should do
the first thing is that I would tell
anyone to
are you sleeping right because if you're
not sleeping right you are causing all
kinds of harms for your body do you have
a ton of stress in your life are you
smoking are you drinking alcohol don't
drink alcohol
are you
eating a healthy diet full of we'll call
it like healthy grains rather than
non-referring around non-refined
carbohydrates easy stuff right that
people should just be doing every single
day are you doing hardcore compound
exercises like deadlifts and squats
those things also help increase
testosterone I was doing all of those
things
and so for them still had low
testosterone still had low testosterone
all right
so that's when they said for us the
answer is very easy and here's the other
thing they said that made me feel super
comfortable they said a majority of
their patients are younger guys just
like me and that's actually the thing
that had the alarm go off in my head
that said whoa is this a really a big
problem here's a kicker
40 of men 40 over 35 suffer from
hormonal imbalances and low testosterone
and no one's willing to talk about it
why won't they talk about it
one
everyone thinks when they're 35 or 40
they just start to slow down they saw
their father slow down around that age
they all just believe that it's a normal
part of life
two
who do you go and tell that you feel
like less of a man who do you go and say
hey
I might have some Edie or my dick's not
working or who do you go and tell and
say look I just don't have as much
excitement for my life and the reality
is that most guys when they go to their
primary care physicians which is the
same thing that I did their doctor says
the same thing there's nothing wrong
with you oh we don't need to check your
testosterone oh by the way let me just
give you an SSRI the amount of hormone
imbalances that are just treated with an
SSRI are shocking what's the SSRI SSRI
sorry antidepressant oh got it yeah I
feel like there's not drug America
that's what they do yeah the drugging
kids in the school is a drug-in uh
middle-aged men like the whole thing I
mean it's a machine so I I ran market
research and business development for a
four billion dollar pharmaceutical brand
at Eli Lilly okay that's our job you
literally go spend 20 million dollars
conducting market research figuring out
which message is going to resonate both
with your Physicians and your patients
and you figure you say this is the
message great let's go ahead and let's
blast it all over the damn Airwaves I
don't want to hear that that's
a lot it's so here's the reality
there's a lot of good that comes from it
but there's also we'll call it maybe an
over prescriptive mindset in the country
when the reality is a large majority of
the problems we go through can all be
solved by lifestyle changes or talk
therapy and the normal or the easy thing
for people to do because they don't want
to put in the work very often is take
this pill take this pill take this pill
so okay you go they say hey we got to
fix this you're doing all these other
things that are right yep
what do they tell you to do outside of
are you sleeping are you eating right
are you squatting are you whatever so
the first thing that I decided to opt
for right and this is the most important
thing
you have to understand all the benefits
but more importantly the side effects
that come along when you take treatment
a lot of great things come out of it and
there's also a lot of changes or things
you have to really watch for
because I was younger and I wanted to
maintain my fertility to be in a place
where I could actually have children I
initially opted for a fertility drug
called Clomid women use it guys have
been using it for the past 35 or 40
years and what that little pill does is
it takes the signal from my head and it
tells my testes to produce more
testosterone naturally
took that for about six months
felt great right all this it worked it
worked it's very gentle it all of a
sudden I started to sleep a little bit
better after I slept a little bit better
I noticed that my recovery was a little
bit better but the most interesting
thing is that
it gives you back your confidence a
little bit right and that confidence is
what you actually can begin to harness
and do other things with and then you
start doing things you couldn't before
and all of a sudden you start to think I
can accomplish the same exact things and
that's part of this feedback cycle
because I think one of the most
important things people have to realize
there's never a silver bullet you take
it's always you take something that
gives you a little bit of something and
you've got to harness that energy and do
something more useful with it
so you start taking that you do it for
six months why did you stop
so I got I mean I am uh started a
company and for me I learned that
there's all of these other tools that I
have at my disposal and I said to myself
I want to live as long as humanly
possible I want to feel as young as
possible I want to be able to accomplish
I want to be able to impact as many
people's lives I build mission-driven
companies and so then I said to myself
okay let me try the testosterone let me
try a baby dose of it and see what it
feels like normal dose of testosterone
is 100 milligrams a week okay I take
about 40 to 50 milligrams a week so a
small dose and just to give you an idea
a bodybuilder probably takes 2 000
milligrams per week right so you're
taking 100 is normal they take 2 000.
is that why they all uh unfortunately
well yes they're huge but also like uh
physically uh but like a lot of them
have heart problems pass away Etc but
keep in mind if you are a bodybuilder
you're probably taking testosterone
you're probably taking antivirus you're
probably taking Anadrol you're probably
taking in a ball you're probably taking
clenobutrol you're taking multiple
medications and you're stacking them
together in a staggered approach so you
gain a bunch of weight and then you lose
a bunch of weight prior to actually
going to concentrating your body through
hell over and over and over again over
and over again for multiple Cycles
throughout your entire life yeah okay so
you start taking a little bit where
you're like this is awesome like what
was the reaction of feeling it's this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a Game Changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
an eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep
keep in mind one I'm not a doctor and
two every person is completely different
in how they how it impacts them and I'll
say this right
the imagine that you've got receptors
all over your cells for testosterone and
so testosterone goes into all your cells
and they have multiple different
biological processes right that's
important now how the testosterone makes
you feel manifests itself in your
personality that's the other important
thing so for me I went from not being
able to think about the future and dream
about bigger things to all of a sudden I
was like holy [ __ ] like this is a second
win I'm gonna be able to do this again
oh my God I can work these hours again
oh my God I can go to the gym like I
used to all of a sudden I could think
like I used to I was reading a whole lot
again all of a sudden I didn't have
didn't have to take those naps during
the middle of the day
I actually at one point thought I might
have been a little bit depressed never
felt that way in my entire life and all
of a sudden that feeling had disappeared
and the moment you're given that it
almost feels like another lease on life
and then I said okay
this isn't something we do then I got
into the whole world of peptides right
and those are other kind of like we'll
call it protein messenger molecules that
you have in your body very often they
can be consumed but most of them are
injected then I got into peptides and
started I would say stacking different
peptides based upon their outcomes in
different combinations to see what they
felt like and then I got into this whole
world of optimization and I said to
myself this is [ __ ] amazing what is a
peptide
so imagine you got seven to ten thousand
different protein messenger molecules in
your body okay what what is that
um so basically uh
hormones got it hormones are very often
protein Messengers there are some very
long ones some very short ones growth
hormones another one as well and so
basically so some Mark McGuire
I that that's who I was thinking about
yeah I don't know if they uh admit it or
not but that's what it is uh at least
accused of doing the human uh growth
hormone yep and so so here's a great
example right one of the peptides or not
even one there's a series of peptides
they sell out there okay that basically
instead of giving you and Dodge or
exogenous growth hormone outside outside
nailed it you're getting he's getting
good at this thing he's gonna take my
damn job
instead of giving yourself more growth
hormone it basically tells your
pituitary gland to tell
other parts of your body to release
growth hormones create more yeah well
could we create more very often it's
release more of it interesting and so
all of a sudden now your body is
naturally releasing now there's
obviously some side effects you've got
to watch out for but it's really
important to understand that
the timing the dose what else you're
stacking it with is all incredibly
important and you should always be doing
it with the help of a physician always
did you ever like go on the internet and
like buy [ __ ] from like China or
anything I've seen people I don't want
to name who they are but I see them
online talking about this it's like yeah
usually I go to this website and like
you like ordered steroids or
testosterone or whatever from like these
random places overseas did you ever uh
either research that do that any of that
all the time really but for different
reasons okay for different reasons like
what reasons so I am obsessed with the
healthcare industry I'm obsessed with
personal health I try I'm a probably a
customer of every Healthcare Company men
and female out there I buy all their
products I bring them home I take them
apart I'll order from multiple Labs I
want to see how it's packaged I want to
see what's actually in it we'll send
them to other labs to have them tested
for for Pure for Purity I also am
constantly looking at What's On The
Fringe that could potentially become a
very real thing in the near future and
we're thinking about how do we move past
testosterone because that was just kind
of what got us initial start
how do people trust the things that they
order off the internet from these other
places like yeah like I gotta imagine if
I was like I'm in the market for
testosterone and uh pick your country
far outside the United States
I I mean I just was you know watching uh
or was I reading I don't remember like
the Halloween candy had fentanyl in it
like they're putting that [ __ ] in uh the
candy
I gotta imagine again I don't think
they're you know putting a pill and
you're like oh I thought I was getting a
liquid because I got this pill but like
you how do you know what you're actually
putting in your body I think that scares
people I don't really that's the reality
right when you're ordering from these
basement pharmacies when you're ordering
overseas you have no clue what you're
putting in your body that's scary Hold
on like I mean it's terrifying to know
that you are ingesting something day
after day or you're injecting something
into yourself arguably like the most
invasive way to actually put a
medication into your body and you
actually have no clue what the hell it
is terrifying and the average person
maybe even the sophisticated person if
they get something can they test it
before they put it in their body like do
can is there like a who does that yeah
like hey I ordered this thing let's make
sure it's really this thing like I'm
assuming most people don't do that no
most people get it and they're like oh
my God I'm so excited I can't can't wait
to try this let's do it
all right uh so as you guys get started
um I forget who introduced us or how we
got connected but at some point we're
like all right you have a company and
I'm like all right what's company uh and
you guys are like testosterone
optimization which I think is important
because it wasn't I don't think in our
initial conversation you correct me if
I'm wrong it was like hey we just have a
testosterone like replacement or like we
want everyone to go and get this
exogenous testosterone injected instead
it was like we want to help optimize for
testosterone levels is that like a fair
well let me let me actually correct that
a little bit right perfect
most other clinics
they will literally say if your cash is
green I don't care what your numbers are
I will prescribe it to you if your cash
is green and you're paying me with cash
we actually take a very different stance
okay we basically say only if you are
hypogonadal which is having clinically
low testosterone as you are tested using
biomarkers on two separate occasions
will we be willing to prescribe you
medication and then more importantly if
you want to continue receiving
medication you've got to get retested
every 90 days if you don't get retested
we don't continue sending you out
medication how much is the test
like how much does that cost so we
charge 45 dollars for your initial test
and your physician consultation okay and
so if you're getting tested every 90
days and what are you receiving because
there's kind of like different things
that people can interface with you all
um
so let me actually maybe go through the
process that might help you understand
right so for forty five dollars you buy
this at home testing kit okay or just
launched it yesterday you can go to lab
core and you give us five dollars and
you can use your use your insurance to
get your biomarkers
we'll then analyze that we analyze eight
different biomarkers we then do a 30
minute audio visual consult between you
and a physician and that consult is the
first 10 minutes you tell us what's
going on in your life it's very deep
therapeutic conversation most guys very
often haven't told anyone about this for
10 years there's a lot of crying a lot
is a strong word there is some crime
next 10 minutes we go over your results
what does it mean what's happening in
your body in the next 10 minutes we
describe here are the benefits but more
importantly the side effects of any
treatment and then we give you different
treatment plans you make a decision if
you decide to go on something like a
testosterone that is a controlled
substance we actually ask you to do a
second confirmatory test
we send you out medication and then
every 90 days we basically say if you
want to continue receiving it we want to
get you tested and it's not because
we just want to test you to test you
it's more importantly we want to make
sure it's safe for you and it's like a
safety thing that what are you looking
for uh or like what would disqualify
someone so they're getting the the every
90 day test what could go wrong what are
you looking for to big oh time out like
we don't need to keep sending this to
you so
there's a couple things
one is sometimes we ask the person to
make a bunch of Lifestyle Changes in
conjunction with it they don't make
those Lifestyle Changes they continue to
drink real hard they continue to smoke a
lot it doesn't make sense that this
medication's for you because you don't
really want to change second thing is
maybe your estrogen levels go up really
high because once again testosterone
converts into estrogen and we say hey
you should remove some of the estrogen
you don't want to remove some of the
estrogen we say okay maybe this
treatment isn't for you because you're
not necessarily being compliant but the
bigger one is
about 15 to 20 percent of people that
take testosterone the amount of red
blood cells they have increases
could be let's say it could be it could
be it's a very what happens if you have
too many red blood cells
it's well that's also Up For Debate
right because technically people that
live in Elevated Places the country and
athletes that train there they have more
red blood cells so they can hold more
oxygen that's why they do it that's why
they do it and you don't hear them
necessarily having problems but if you
have you have an elevated hematocrit
level which is a total number of red
blood cells and you were to have to go
for an operation you could theoretically
bleed a little bit more right also
theoretically you could have a higher
degree of having a cardiovascular event
theoretically and so generally we
basically say if your hematocrit level
increases you need to have a what they
call a therapeutic phlebotomy that's a
real fancy word therapeutic philosophy
just means it sounds sounds badass
doesn't it yeah what is it you just draw
on your blood you're donating your blood
I'm one of those people that it happens
to every we'll call it four months I've
got to go donate my blood I'll do it all
day long I just saw a study and now I'm
you know a scientist obviously I was
reading a study that I saw somebody post
on Twitter of course uh it was
fascinating it said that you have a I
forget highly positioned it so not
medical advice you should go find
instead of yourself uh
the people who donated blood regularly
had longer lives
and they clearly called out it could be
because there's a connection between
donating blood and somehow leads to
longer lifespan or whatever or it could
just be that healthy people donate blood
more and therefore they end up having a
longer life so they didn't go as far as
to say like it's you know certain or
anything like that but they did find
this I guess correlation or kind of
unique data point around donating blood
and lifespan that I found fascinating I
was like huh is it because you're like
body has to like almost clean itself out
as you're donating blood or you know I
don't know but like interesting I
actually am going to go read about this
myself because I hope that is just
another reason why I live longer
it just came out and I saw somebody and
like whenever I see these studies I'm
always like okay like I would like to
see many of them right instead of all
this stuff I didn't change any of my
behavior I didn't run to go donate blood
or anything but it does feel like uh the
world maybe in general is getting
smarter about some of this some of the
optimization some of the impact of
various activities you could do uh
obviously there's like the DNA stuff but
also I think now you're starting to see
just the average you know average person
being like Oh there are now tools
available to me that may not have been
available to me 10 20 years ago Elite
athletes
multi-billionaires had this stuff right
now it's getting kind of commoditized
down from a price point standpoint where
if I go find a provider that does this
really well high quality you know as an
over and over is safe like all these
different things
I now have access to what you know the
Kings had access to you know 100 years
ago or whatever God you nailed it it's
crazy you nailed it now there are a lot
of things that drive that well actually
let me ask this question
you're 34. how old do you feel in your
mind
oh in my mind I'm like a 12 year old kid
yes like an idiot hold on that's life's
Dirty Little Secret yeah the older we
get the more successful we are the more
disposable income we have the more
wisdom we have we feel like we're 12. or
21 yeah 12 God bless you that sounds
like a gift right and that's the truth
of it now the other thing is we've
watched our parents go through chronic
conditions it's
ugly it's messy it's painful on the
other hand our parents are living longer
so it creates this huge example for us
that we don't want to live that life
then on top of it too a lot of us played
Sports when we were younger and it's
around us using social media that you
can feel so much better as you actually
get older and you can take advantage of
all this disposable income and wisdom
that you have or this family time that
you have and what's happening is people
are going well that person can have it
and I saw how they did it they're no
different than I am should I work with
them I should be able to do that and all
of a sudden you start to say to yourself
you're in your late 30s you're in your
40s your 50s and you're going huh I can
go to Starbucks and I can spend four or
five dollars every single day 150 bucks
200 bucks over the course of the month
and it's or I could go and have myself
optimize and have my help taken care of
and I'll feel way better than those cups
of coffee and I'll live longer so
when people start to use the external
testosterone what do they normally
report is it just higher energy better
focus better mood like those types of
things it's different for everyone going
back to everyone is so incredibly
individual and it manifests itself based
on your personality but generally what
you hear is and I wish so we have a the
way our product is built is fascinating
we literally have a Facebook like
community
in the middle of our product with people
seeing different medications and
biomarkers alongside of it and there's
like 20 000 men that are constantly
talking about these positive changes
they've had in their life what you very
often see is
I was in the lowest part of my life I
felt like I couldn't get and get on the
ground and play with my kids anymore I
feel like I couldn't have a conversation
with my significant other because I
didn't have the patience or I didn't
have the confidence to look him in the
eye and I always wanted to walk away
from my problems or I couldn't go to
work and I couldn't focus to go and
crush it and earn more money for the
people I love her and you're a father
now and you know what it's like to want
to take care of your daughter and the
first things they start to say is all of
a sudden my sleep started to improve and
then because I was sleeping better now
all of a sudden I wake up I feel a
little bit more refreshed there's a
little bit less chatter in my mind all
of a sudden the anxiety starts to go
away a little bit all of a sudden my
energy levels start to come back all of
a sudden I can start to think a little
bit more deeply into problems and do
things I used to do when I was a little
bit younger and then it starts these
interesting set of Cascades where their
life actually improves because they have
this energy back right and it's
interesting because when you think about
the biggest thing we lose as we get
older is energy and so a lot of guys
come to us and say like look it's not
about the muscle it's not about the sex
because by the way those things are all
wonderful it's really about how do I get
more energy and mental Clarity and this
is the most important thing so I can
feel like myself again it's a hugely
huge identity issue that they're
grappling with I've for a long time had
this theory that coffee consumption in
America has exploded yep and a lot of it
was due to physiological changes that
people were going through and so uh they
were using the coffee to get the
quote-unquote energy right to then push
through the next couple hours to go get
another cup of coffee like it became
almost like a drug right
um I don't know if they're if that's
completely true or whatever but like the
charts line up right of like in
hindsight now as I've looked at it
testosterone's dropping coffee uh
consumptions and exploding and like
energy is kind of one of the the common
things here yeah
what is interesting to me though is that
like
in some ways coffee is the Band-Aid 100
and
testosterone levels whether it is just
my sleeping eating correctly like kind
of what we'll call it natural stuff or
it's anything like you guys would do or
uh people could go to a doctor too for
whatever
that's really the like true solution
and I'm wondering the people who you all
work with do you see their coffee
consumption going down like that would
be like the other side of the equation
that is a fascinating question
and I am 100 gonna go pull our community
yeah and send an email out to folks
because now I am really really
interested to find that answer but if
your theory holds correct I bet you it
starts to make sense I can even say from
personal
experience
My overall caffeine consumption has been
reduced dramatically as I've really
figured out how to fine tune myself yeah
what do you do uh from like a let's just
kind of go through the different aspects
so like Diet wise what do you do uh to
to help supplement kind of the
optimization work you do
so I think it here's the other really
important thing right in different parts
of her life we're trying to achieve
different things and when you're in a
different part of your life your diet's
legitimately going to change right I
worked No Lie 16 hours a day six days a
week on the seventh day I take a little
bit of time off and I constantly try
doing it over and over and over again
and also try integrating my family in it
and so I went through this phase where I
was taught on a hard keto diet because
it helped my mental Clarity and it
helped me maintain very low body fat
because I couldn't actually go to the
gym as often as I'd like to when I say
as often I mean as long as I'd like to
that lasted probably about a year until
I realized my my bad LDL levels had went
up a little bit too high because my body
specifically was susceptible to those
kind of bad changes a lot of other
people's aren't and so I hired another
trainer we went on we'll call it more of
a carnivore diet I didn't really like
that I hired another trainer and
interestingly when I say a trainer I
mean like a dietitian
I actually eat so incredibly well now
and I consistently lose weight I
consistently add muscle to myself I
obviously don't like being too big
um and the way my diet is is I have 200
grams of protein per day I've got 120 to
140 grams of carbs I've got a bunch of
healthy fats that go in there I eat very
very healthy but I will tell you you can
cook healthy food so it feels like
you're eating at a restaurant and it
takes very little prep right but like
what like what what is I don't know last
week what did you eat like some of the
meals is it like you go and you cook a
steak and you like broccoli is it like
no broccoli's bad and uh so that you're
not touching that like easy easy way to
think about it right so let's just say
I've got to consume 120 grams of carbs
and 200 grams of protein okay
I'll go get for for let's call it for 60
grams in the morning I'm gonna have a
shake that has incredibly we'll call it
clean protein so not a lot of additives
in terms of a protein powder I'll throw
a cup of oats in there and we'll call it
that's my 50 grams of carbs to get the
day started then my next meal in the day
I'll have we'll call it like six ounces
of ground turkey with
um we'll call it two wheat tortillas and
it'll be like the healthiest most
wholesome Mexican meal during the middle
of the day right it's hard to get that
much food down yeah then my next meal in
the day will probably be something like
call it like a a cup of jasmine rice
with all kinds of spices
um chives and then I'll do do you have
an air fryer by the way no but I've seen
this yeah I've seen these I've seen
these how can you how can you be so
successful not having air fryer I I will
tell you this chicken thighs out of an
air fryer superb yeah even steaks out of
an air fryer superb
so I'll do that in an air fryer I'm
sorry I got to tell you the truth it's
unbelievable and then at the end of the
night I'll have like a scoop of protein
and I'll probably have like uh like a a
scoop of fire right it's a lot of food
during the day that's a [ __ ] and I and
here's the best thing about it it feels
like so much food at the beginning but
the moment you start eating it you
interestingly your body and this is the
most counter-intuitive thing
you start to lose weight and your body
gets used to it and it constantly craves
that
when you do that what do you then do in
the gym like what is an average workout
look like
I'm in and out of the gym in 45 minutes
okay right so I get in once again
I hire a trainer just because I like
working with a professional but what
I'll do is
give an example of my workout today
right jumped into the hotel gym did my
triceps did my biceps probably for like
call it 25 minutes jumped on a stair
stepper for 20 minutes I was in and out
in 45 minutes I always hit a sauna every
single day that's arguably been one of
the best things I've ever had what does
the sauna do for you like why this sauna
ooh so there's this concept right
of
I'm trying to think of how to simplify
it
when you put your body under just enough
stress your body senses that something's
happening and it starts all of a sudden
activating all these healing properties
or mechanisms and it basically your body
starts healing itself and there's when I
say mechanisms let's call it there's
seven or eight different Pathways right
one of the pathways is you have these
things called senison cells these are
cells that have probably been around in
your body for way too long they're
causing all kinds of Havoc sometimes
your body starts cleaning those up and
it also depends upon which sometimes I
use a hot sauna which is in my gym or I
have an infrared sauna in my place
sometimes I'll use the empress so hot
soil is going to basically going to heat
up the surrounding air about 180 to 220
degrees and so you're heating up
yourself from the outside in versus an
infrared sauna is going to probably be
115 to 130 140 degrees and it's going to
penetrate the first couple layers of
your skin start a little bit further
inside and then you're gonna and then
eventually sweat that way
is that bad for you like well there's no
there's infrared shooting into my skin I
don't know if I'm cool with that what
does that do baby why are you glowing
today yeah what does that do I don't
know so here's the thing right there are
certain infrared saunas okay that have
what they call they they have too many
emfs uh basically there's certain
infrared saunas that are janky created
out of bad materials use bad lights use
bad woods where they're leaking pocs and
so you have to make sure that you're
getting the right brand okay
um and there are a couple great Brands
out there right there's there's sunlight
and there's clear light
what about uh the sauna for you is just
the stress of the body that then makes
you sweat that kind of tells your body
hey like clean me out and and be
prepared I think that's probably like
the easiest most simplistic way to do it
but then I mean and you just sit in the
sauna you don't do it you know I
meditate every single time religiously
all right I've seen people they're like
I work out in the sauna people like I
listen to music whatever like you just
sit there the number of guys that the
number of people I hear having like deep
Comfort I mean so on a time on a
Saturday morning is what do you do at
the night at the bar before what did you
do last night at the bar and how stupid
were you those are the conversations on
a Saturday morning got it
when you
do the sauna you mentioned cold plunge
earlier as well you do that every day
every day is a stretch probably like
twice a week okay what does that do
so cold plunge is going to reduce a ton
of the inflammation in your body okay it
also is going to reduce it's also when
you think about the concept this is a
crazy concept to think about you're
going to get into water
that's 35 to 45 degrees do you know how
cold what that feels like is it's really
cold I don't know that much about
science but I think 32 degrees means it
freezes it's done you've done so
and so what you basically do is you have
to
you've got to do some breathing
exercises and Center yourself then you
submerge yourself in the water once you
subred yourself in the water head goes
under everything everything okay um and
you got to do it quick don't do that
slow let me get in it's going to be even
worse you just got to rip the Band-Aid
off you got to get right in then all of
a sudden what happens is your heart rate
goes up your body feels like it's under
stress same exact kind of concept but
then what ends up happening is this
really cool thing where if you br if
you've done the right breathing exercise
and you can steady your mind your mind
goes completely steady and you're just
focused in the water and you're
breathing in and out and all of a sudden
all the other chatter that you have in
your life it disappears and advantages
because all you are doing is thinking
about how you [ __ ] survive yeah
and so do you go back and forth like uh
I've done it before uh where you like
you go to a hotel and you're like I'm
gonna go to the sauna wow
I got a cold pool
somebody's somewhere in a podcast said
like go hot cold hot cold or whatever
like do you do that or are you just like
I go in the sauna some days and then I
do the cold pool something so I'll say
when I have like a day day to myself I'm
gonna go sauna for like 15 minutes I'm
gonna go cold plunge for five minutes
there's a guy named Eric Henman out
there that swears by 20 minutes of sauna
10 minutes of cold plunge do it three
times an hour and a half now the other
thing too is you get an amazing high
from this man the endorphin rush that
you get once you hit that right point
I mean it's just it lasts for the whole
day it lasts for the whole day
that's crazy it's wonderful man but now
here's the other curveball too because
now you ask yourself when do I do it
you would think that the best time to do
it is right after a workout actually you
should separate your workout and you
should separate your son and your cold
time yeah why
It generally when you work out you're
trying to put stress on your muscles and
you want them to grow a little bit when
you jump in a cold plunge right
afterwards you're reducing inflammation
so you're probably reducing some of how
that that damage per se
um and so really it's just Nuance right
you're not really sitting there and
saying am I doing this thing perfectly
if you just do it that's a huge battle I
need to tell you something uh nobody's
listening so like it's uh it's fine but
I did the hot cold hot cold thing and
then I was like I'm exhausted and I felt
like such a loser because I was like man
I went in the uh sauna that I went in
the cold one and I wouldn't last time I
did it probably a couple months ago I
three four times back and forth or
whatever and I remember an hour later I
think I need a nap like I'm actually
tired why was I tired
is it just because the body got so
stressed out let me think about it this
way
um how often do you do podcasts podcasts
yeah oh I don't know the 1200 and a
couple years you were an absolute
podcast machine yeah I promised you the
majority of your guests they come in
here they talk for two hours and they're
like God damn
tired I got to go back so much for
telling him to sleep a lot of this has
to do with being accustomed to it
getting your body used to it and for you
you can probably do these reps in your
sleep you probably have done them in
your sleep and you're barely even here
because you guys are sleeping right now
yeah
I knew it so that's really it is if if
you kind of build up the ability to do
this back and forth and then it could
you actually like go back to the
caffeine conversation like if you let's
say you did this in the morning right so
you went uh Asana
cold plunge back and forth a couple
times could that be enough to like start
your day where you might not need
caffeine that's what a lot of people do
really I'm dead serious huh I'll tell
you something really so going back to
your body is consistently changing and
in order to figure out how to really be
up healthy and optimize it you've got to
constantly Tinker with your body
about two years ago
for whatever reason and it happened to
coincide with becoming very healthy my
body became allergic to coffee and
allergic I love coffee okay I've always
loved coffee when I say allergic I would
drink coffee and my whole head would
feel like it's heating up so much to the
point where literally I'd had to put my
head in the freezer it was the most
bizarre thought
go to my doctors we've never heard of
this we start all doing research I'm
very lucky that I have some very good
doctors and what we find out is that
some small portion of the population
develops sensitivity to caffeine and
specifically from coffee okay I had to
stop coffee immediately interestingly
matcha worked out for me and
interestingly my body two years later
says you know what
I want you to enjoy coffee again and so
this also goes back to if you're trying
to figure out how to optimize your life
whether it's your health your mindset
your business you're constantly tweaking
it around and it actually becomes like a
great source of Joy because once you
figure out the unlock you feel way
better than you did before so
it's fascinating that your body can like
something not like something change like
that
um
but one of the things I've thought a lot
about is I don't think I drink coffee
tells me 27 28. yep oh that's that's a
that's a gift I think that our yeah I
think I had like a bad experience I
literally think if I remember crook I
was like 12 and I like tried coffee and
it was too hot and I burnt my mouth and
I was like oh [ __ ] like well you guys
crazy like like all y'all are Savage
tongues out here drinking this like
whatever the guy like just I remember I
literally remember where I was I like
drink it I was like I'm out and for
whatever year for like 15 years I didn't
drink it
had it iced coffee was a game changer
right and so you know you'd start not
having like once a week whatever now I
drink I don't know 350 400 like I drink
a lot of coffee right oh that's a lot of
coffee yeah so like I'll have uh and
I've talked about this before people are
like well that's crazy is I may have
like a large uh Starbucks iced coffee
which I did not know how much caffeine
was in there there's a [ __ ] ton of
caffeine or what I might do is I might
do like a a double espresso at you know
8 A.M or so and then again at like 12
30. it's like four shots right
throughout the day not that's not as
crazy as uh uh other people but like I
stole a lot
that's not that long to go from like I
don't drink that to like I'm I need a
lot I'm addicted yeah and so like I've
I've thought like I haven't decided
completely but in 2023 is next year yeah
2023 I thought about like can I go the
whole year and not drink coffee one time
as like a challenge to myself
scares the [ __ ] out of me because if I
don't drink coffee in the morning I'm
like you know got a headache yep but
like let's say that I wanted to do that
what would the path to like getting off
the caffeine and like are there things
that whether it's testosterone whether
it's some of these other protocols like
optimization stuff whatever that you
think or you've seen other people do to
replace like the caffeine intake let me
ask you do you meditate meditate yeah
yeah but like not like the uh I call
like the woo-woo meditation and then
like the like I clear my mind yeah and
like I I walk a lot and so like that's
like kind of like a uh I don't have my
phone and you know I'm like kind of
calmed down whatever so it's not like I
think true meditation as much as it's
just like I clear my mind
but I have some friends that like I got
one friend he's like the most torturous
thing a human can do in today's society
is go sit in a room and just be quiet
close your eyes for 30 minutes and don't
fall asleep it's a long it's a long time
to close your eyes man it sounds like
it's not no phone no nothing like
nothing the world might run by me he's
like yeah you don't you don't got pain
tolerance for that right it's like I
don't do that stuff but like I do go for
walks and everything but not uh I'll
tell you consider meditation so
I started meditating about 10 years ago
okay right um like the woo-woo kind of
medic meditation or like I go for a walk
clear my mind like I grabbed a headspace
app and I start meditating five minutes
a day okay right and I was running my
first company
first company you run always tons of
work always tons of decisions to make I
was also a cigarette smoker right I used
to smoke cigarettes for some period of
time and one day I was like I gotta I
gotta stop this it's horrible for me and
I gotta figure out how to get myself
together a little bit better and so I
started meditating first six months I
was like this [ __ ] your friend that
was in a room for 30 minutes I felt
exactly like him I was like Jesus what
am I doing just myself then all of a
sudden
started to notice and I'll talk about
gratitude exercise in a second I was
just always calm and no matter what got
thrown at me I just didn't care I just
always came to the conclusion like
that's cool I'm gonna solve that and
then all of a sudden literally I snapped
a finger didn't smoke another cigarette
really just went like that
then all of a sudden I was like oh my
God I feel like I have more energy in my
life stopped drinking as much coffee
all because of the meditation you
attributed to it's it really started
with that now the next thing I layered
in and this is fascinating as I started
doing gratitude exercises first thing
what is that
so the easy way to do it is you
basically grab your Apple notes you
write three things you're really happy
for in the morning there's an app I use
it's called five minute Journal but
generally when I do it as I wake up in
the morning
chug my water really quickly now this is
all complete automatic I don't have to
think about it and my brain's like in a
half woken up state right
then I sit and think about three things
I am absolutely grateful for my life and
so it takes a little bit of effort for
you to go I'm grateful about this thing
and then you sit and you think about it
and you hold it in your mind's eye for a
second and you feel it I think about man
I'm so grateful for my mother I'm so
grateful for my team I'm so grateful
that I get to live my dream out every
single day and build these amazing
companies I'm so grateful for my
girlfriend for my father whatever it is
my best friend and when you start
working that muscle of gratefulness
first thing in the morning in that kind
of mind stay and you're writing them
down and you're also writing down what
are the three things you want to
accomplish that day all of a sudden
every and this probably started
happening like three months in I'd be at
a at a lunch with a person I [ __ ]
hated and I'd be like God I'm just so
grateful to be with this [ __ ]
and you're like what just happened and
then you realize you're actually just
happy all the time and the littlest
things in life give you so much joy and
you couple that with the fact that your
mind is a whole lot calmer and you don't
get attached to things the way you used
to emotionally you let them kind of go
by you realize so much of the energy
that we use up in our life is to hold on
to things in an emotionally process them
when the reality is like you don't have
to react to most of those things and you
can actually just be so much happier and
that was like the real unlock in my life
which was I was like oh my God like
I'm just always happy great I don't need
to be constantly pushing energy down my
throat all the time and I know that
sounds woo-woo but the moment I believe
in this dude like the moment it happens
I do it differently though what's
interesting is when you talk to really
really successful people
a lot of them are just so happy about
life a lot of them are constantly always
giving back a lot of them are constantly
they feel I mean some of them are
absolutely crazy in there of course and
and but the other chunk of them like
they're very happy with whatever happens
and they never get frazzled by crazy
things like literally the number of
problems that happen in my business on a
daily basis
most people they lose their mind over
one problem there are 15 [ __ ]
Problems going on my life every single
day and I'm just happy man I feel
grateful that they're part of my life
I'm gonna say something I think a lot of
people are gonna be like wait what is he
talking about so that there's uh two
things one is a something that people
see publicly but I don't think they
realize why I do it and the second is uh
it's like a secret that all my good
friends uh when they hear me say it
they're like dude no you don't believe
that the public thing is every morning I
wake up and I don't do it every time
exactly when I wake up but like within
the first hour yep I get on Twitter and
I tweet good morning today is going to
be a great day let's get after it
relentlessly love it every day love it
and people are like why do you do that
and at some point I realized that
there was a correlation between the days
I did not tweet that and having shitty
days
and like I knew in the back of my head
like there's a bunch of studies right if
you like wake up and read three positive
articles versus three negative articles
you're more likely to say it a better
day like there's all these things that
like kind of sort of hit around it
whatever that's my version I think of
this like gratitude thing but the second
thing that I believe uh was [ __ ] uh
sounds woo-woo but like I believe this
is the manifestation yes I have a friend
that I talked about all the time I'm
like there are people who go through
their life and they're like uh I kind of
sort of like want this thing or like
this goal or whatever and like if you
ask them at any point like hey like what
are you working on what do you whatever
they're like it's this thing this week
it's this thing next week it's this
thing whatever but this one friend who
uh I won't name but uh uh he'll laugh
when he hears this
him and I text all day long
and it's like a weird like dude version
of manifestation of it's like here's a
goal and like just drive towards it over
and over and it's like all we talk about
right and like both of our wives are
like you two are insane like please stop
right he's like no like you don't
understand like this is my goal right
now and like it's not like some big
crazy thing all the time right it could
just literally be like something to do
that week or whatever
but it's like if you put two people next
to each other and one of them is focused
and like constantly thinking about it
and like whatever they can do to get
there and the other person is going
who do you think is going to get there
like obviously the person who's like
focused on it knows what they're trying
to go after whatever and so like I do
think uh there's been this like rise of
like all like uh the like super super
woo stuff um uh crystals right like like
that whole world oh my God which uh I
got a crash course from uh uh my wife
and she was explaining to me uh um was
the woman a goop and like that whole
world like all right I don't understand
that but like uh no offense to them just
that's not my that's not my world I I I
don't understand it
but like the manifestation stuff like
okay cool I can get there but like
manifestation is just another word for
like Obsession which is another word for
Focus which is another word you know
what I mean like you can kind of like
look at and you're like oh throughout
history like people have done a lot of
this stuff
they just talked about it differently or
they like executed it differently
because like what you talk about this
gratitude Journal
like the stoics were doing a lot of [ __ ]
that sounds pretty similar right it
sounds you know you you hit on something
that's very important right you have
like we'll call it the goop crowd and
then you got the pop crowd
I'm cool with everybody but here's the
reality is that
whether you and it's very similar to
religion right that I'm definitely out I
just want to be I'm Switzerland
religion is it or the goop versus pop
crowd and I know I'm making this up so I
don't want to put you in the middle of
it the reality is that they're just
different ways of going the same exact
thing and whatever way works for you at
the end of the day because what's
beautiful thing about life is you get to
pick and choose exactly what your flavor
is that's all that matters yeah and the
manifestation thing is fascinating in
itself right because at the end of the
day if you really think deeply about it
it is something in your soul or your
mind's eye that says I believe I can do
this and then somehow you take that and
you literally manifest it into reality
by consistently obsessive and going
after this with maniacal focus and have
you read the book Think and Grow Rich
yeah it's one of my three books that I
always tell people I read at 20 years
old changed my life
when you read Think and Grow Rich and
you hear like this god-like voice of and
you will think and manifest in these
sound waves will will permeate the world
and these organelles and you're like
Jesus what the hell is this and then you
manifest something in real life you're
like oh my God this is what he's talking
about there's a guy named Dr Joe Da
Silva have you ever heard of him no
who's that so you should definitely read
this book
um
so basically right Dr Joe had a bad
bicycle accident doctor said he would
never walked he sat around and basically
thought about his spine basically
growing back over the course of X number
of months and all of a sudden he was
walking and he was riding a bike faster
than Physicians ever thought he would
and the he wrote a book
that's called becoming Supernatural it
is not the easiest read and there are
parts of it that definitely sound
woo-woo but it is the execution of what
manifestation looks like in the in the
real life if you want to actually
implement it right now I'm talking a
little bit more sounding more like
business focused but the reality is that
anyone can achieve what they want but
they have to legitimately believe in
themselves and they have to figure out
how to take the steps to put that into
action like let's be honest right
five six years ago you weren't living
this life you had this vision and you
said hey I want to make sure that I turn
this thing into reality I want to have a
well-listened to podcast I want to make
sure that I can actually go and build
businesses from the ground up and you
said to yourself I'm going to literally
focus and get that done and the reality
is that all started from a thought and
it sounds for most people they just
can't they're like well I think about
things all the time but I can't do them
and you're like yeah because you don't
really believe you can do them yeah and
yeah I'm guessing you tell yourself all
the time I can do this and you and your
friend texting back and forth that's
what it is it's a buddy system to be
like no dude is it too ambitious [ __ ] it
you can do it I also think uh there's a
self-belief there's a competition thing
like my brothers and I are super
competitive so it's always like you know
who who did what and the whole thing
um
get who uh
maybe it was Keith or a boy was recently
on a podcast and I hate that um uh uh
giving him a Tailwind for his commentary
uh but he was talking about the fact
that uh he's never met someone who's
successful
who wasn't somewhat egotistical that
doesn't mean you got to go be like
arrogant and like the negative side
effects of it but he was basically
saying like the self-confidence is
actually really really important to
believe something is possible yep right
and I you know obviously uh there's like
the Roger Bannister you know kind of
examples all that stuff
but I wonder how much of the like
self-confidence and the uh belief you
can accomplish something is like
physiological your body is optimized to
be in a place where like it takes a
level of Happiness optimism you know
like a belief that you can handle
resilience or handle obstacles like like
all these little things that add up to
then be in a mental state where you
think something is possible because the
truth is that like I don't know go to
the extreme people who are depressed
don't usually like I think I can do this
or I can do that it's actually the
opposite they like are telling
themselves all the time they can't do
something so like how important do you
think that like the optimization of the
body is for like the mental stuff
I think that people can have
an inordinate amount of self-belief in
themselves from very different
situations and I'll give you two
different examples one situation is your
father beat the [ __ ] out of you when you
were young and you had to figure out how
to get out of that house and you had to
go figure out how to raise yourself and
because of that you have self-belief and
you then believe that you can achieve
whatever you want the other side of it
is you had a mother that was incredibly
supportive and told you you can do it
you can achieve everything you want and
she built that part of yourself up so
you have self-confidence because of that
and so I think that people come at it
from very different angles but I think
that once you get there
if you start understanding that there
are these other hacks mindfulness cold
plunges saunas optimizing your hormones
you can actually level yourself up a
little bit faster but I think that to
say
everyone that is successful is
egotistical and they probably have the
same kind of egotisticism would probably
be a a stretch of a statement and so I
think that I will say this though
becoming so disciplined in my life has
become a great sense of joy for me and
I'm not and when I don't want to be
disciplined I'm not disciplined right
that's like one of the beautiful things
about life is that you can take it a day
or two days off and you can snap
yourself right back into place and I
think that what a lot of people think is
that you have to be perfect and no one
is perfect no one is perfect and the
beautiful thing about life also is you
can consistently choose to change paths
however you want and getting back to
your appointment a point of does your
body need to be optimized in order for
you to be self-confident I think that
the discipline whether it's you being
the best Knitter you possibly want to be
or making sure that you wake up and go
to the gym every single morning the
discipline and proving yourself that you
can be disciplined is what gives you
confidence in very many instances
so we've talked about like optimizing
your body of this mental thing we
weren't planning to talking about this
but I could talk about that all day long
you think people are going to live to
110 years old
the average uh life expectancy in
America right now uh has gone down
recently but uh it's like 77 I think
somewhere 77 78 years old
that's a big leap to a hundred why do
you think the life expectancy is going
to extend so much
so I watched my father right we brutally
touched upon this
live for 30 years of some of the most
I'd say horrible chronic conditions on
the technology that we have today
if he had eaten better
if he had learned how to reduce his
stress if he had taken his diabetes more
seriously
he would have probably lived until he
was 90. that's how long his parents
lived
um I think a whole generation of people
eat bad yep
don't exercise yep and
their kids
tell them yep you're screwing up 100.
and there's a uh some of it is a
Defiance I'm not gonna listen to my kids
my kids aren't you know what my kids
know type thing and another element of
is the lifestyle like the Hat the
habitual nature of their lifestyle makes
it you would have to make such drastic
changes and like that's hard you know
how hard it is to break habit crazy it's
so difficult and especially if that
habit has been ingrained into you since
you were a child and you watched your
parents do it it becomes even more
difficult and
it's it's interesting I watched my
father pass and I loved him with all I
love him with all my heart and at the
same time as he was going he told me he
was like look you're doing everything
right make sure that you teach your kids
how to do this make sure you keep on
pushing your message and your mission
out there and I think that when people
start taking their health seriously in
combination with all the technological
and medical advances that are coming out
we will live that long and here's a
qualifier if we want to you're talking
about an average age of an American I
think you will see far more people
getting to 100 110 if they are taking
care of themselves I'm in this really
interesting world that I optimize
hormones and I work with people that
really care about health and I'm not
lying when I say this the number of 80
year old people I see that look like
they're there in their mid-40s is
shocking their minds have the plasticity
of a 40 year old they have the
enthusiasm probably of a 20 year old and
they have like the when you look at
their skin their skin looks so
incredibly Supple because they've been
taking care of themselves for all this
period of time and the other thing
that's interesting is
I interviewed 150 guys before I started
this company because I wanted to make
sure this problem wasn't something I had
in my mind and I basically spent an hour
and a half with them we put a camera on
like this and I said tell me about your
life tell me about how you what you
think about old age what you think about
death and here's the biggest takeaway
this is going to be shocking but not
shocking the 50 year old or 60 year old
men that thought they were young they
looked like they were there in their 30s
they felt like they were in the 30s
their enthusiasm came through the 30
year old men that would literally say
things like oh like 50 or 60. they
looked 50 or 60. their their bodies
their mannerisms their mindset all of it
drives it and so so much of what you do
is your mindset is how you think about
your life and what you can actually
continue to achieve or what you want to
achieve or what how happy you are now
that being said
I do think we're going to live far
longer now here's the important thing
I'm 40. you're 35 we touched upon this
you'll have 65 good years of life ahead
of you and so you're probably not
thinking at 65 I'm going to retire I'm
going to go off and what are you going
to do for 35 years I have no clue you're
gonna be bored as all how you're going
to think about what else can I achieve
with my life what are the other
experiences I can have how can I work
with how can I spend time with my
daughters you probably have sons their
kids and so when you start to think
about your life being that long it
fundamentally changes the Arc of your
life and you start to redefine how you
think about it and so I think what a lot
of people do is I'll use my age as a
perfect example at 40 we start to think
well our fathers they probably start to
slow down a little bit they 50 was
around the corner that's when they
really started hanging things up and
they were just counting down their years
until they got to 65 so they can retire
versus I'm going and a lot of my friends
are saying whoa going back I feel like a
12 year old in my mind oh my God I got
these parents I got to take care of I
got this family that I love and I want
to take care of and be around for them
as long as possible I never knew a love
like this existed before I had children
and they're saying how can I and
selfishly I want to feel good I want to
continue going across it I want to
continue playing pickleball or tennis
how do I put myself in a position where
I can achieve that and those things are
right when we went back to it what's
your mindset what are the habits you
have in your life how are you optimizing
your health and if you do those things
and this goes back to your comment about
if you optimize your your body it will
give you the foundation to go figure out
how you can go achieve or optimize the
rest of your life and that's a lot of
what we do right we work with guys and
we tell them it's not just taking this
shot or this pill and your life is going
to turn around like you have to change
as a person yeah I was telling you
earlier I uh read the book uh being
mortal by a tool gawandi and in the book
there's a lot of shocking things but
there's two main things I think I took
away from uh at least the uh uh uh like
maybe the first half of the book is uh
first the experience or relationship
that most people have with aging and
death in America is very different than
many other countries
um he makes a point uh at one point he
talks about I think is his grandfather
great grandfather lives to like a
hundred or something uh back in India
and uh what does he do he has family he
has uh one of his kids he's got
grandkids around they're taking care of
them like the experience of age and
death is actually inside the home with
family members and he Compares it to the
United States where he's a physician and
he's like the age experience and death
experience in America is in a hospital
yep and he's like these are two
different things because guess what
guess who's taking care of the 95 year
old person in the hospital somebody they
don't know yeah
just taking care of them at their home
somebody they know they're a kid they're
whatever right so like he he that is
like one interesting but the second
thing is he talks about uh the death the
physical death of the body why how does
that happen and he basically says
there's one of two schools of thought
that people have tried to understand the
first being like do you basically just
you're a machine you're a machine that
works it works it works then all of a
sudden like 13 shuts off and you die or
is it wear and tear like over long
periods of time it degrades it degrades
it degrades and then like eventually you
die and his belief which maybe some
people disagree with but his belief is
more wear and tear than it's not and so
to your point about like good habits
compound over long periods of time and
like by the time that somebody gets into
old age if they've been doing the right
things like they live a much better life
that would fit alongside his view of
like if you basically prevent wear and
tear if you do maintenance work right
then you're going to be in a much better
position 40 50 years uh later than if
you just like [ __ ] it let's see how you
know let's see what my Bible does let's
just see what the human body can do like
that doesn't seem so great you you're
completely right I actually
I I didn't realize
how all the work I put in
since I was 18 or 19 or 20 would
legitimately compound and now we'll call
it like as a 40 year old when I work
with a lot of my friends or I hang out
with them and I look at what they can do
with themselves how they can play with
their kids what are they trying to do in
life
we're two very different people and I
didn't realize how all that hard work
I'd put in has literally compounded and
given me this Foundation that is
arguably like if you said I'm gonna take
your car away I'm gonna take your your
apartment away I'm gonna take everything
that you worked for away I'd be like
yeah that's cool I got this health and
I've got this mindset and literally I'm
just gonna go and do it again
and I think that
it's so hard to understand how these
things compound because there isn't like
a true blueprint or they're not enough
stories about what compounding looks
like and we're such instant
gratification people that you're like oh
man let me grab that let me grab that
beer when I come home from work and sit
on the couch for a little while you
can't necessarily think long and I think
that as people we probably need to
change that narrative a little bit which
once again really hard right really
really hard what do you think really
drives the behavior change for the
people that you see change their
behavior is it a mental thing is it uh
they write a schedule like what
ultimately is the behavior change Rock
Bottom really rock bottom they're just
like they have nowhere else to go change
or what you generally so when I
interviewed these men right and then we
eventually went and validated it with
about 5 000 men this is what I used to
do at a Pharma company and so
you basically say
um
here is 21 years old right and then
we're going to look at your life going
out this way and I want you to chart
your health from when you were 21 years
old this is what you see
it's 21 years old I feel like I could
run through a wall I went I hung out
with my friends I was 25 years old I go
to the bars all the time I'd have a
blast with my life I met this wonderful
girl we ended up falling in love I ended
up getting married got married all of a
sudden I had two kids that I mean I
loved them but God that got life got a
little bit harder started getting some
weight all of a sudden my my work
started piling up and then all of a
sudden my boss was really horrible to
work with I looked down it was 15 years
later and I'd gained 30 pounds I could
barely get out of bed in the morning I
was constantly pissed off getting up
every single morning wondering is this
my life and they say they're at the
bottom of their life and they're like I
can either turn over because it feels
like I'm in a grave and I could get
progressively worse or I could look at
the man who I was and say I want to
change and then that is the point with
which people they kind of almost go
through like an Enlightenment they have
to look at themselves in the mirror and
[ __ ] want it so bad and they say okay
I'm gonna actually change my behavior
first thing I'm going to do is maybe
I'll just have one glass of water a day
maybe instead of taking the elevator I'm
just going to take a set of stairs all
of a sudden and the second you start
accomplishing a couple things right it
it
exercises that confidence muscle you
have and once they've gotten a year two
years into it they're so much further
from that person at the bottom they
can't even recognize them yeah and
that's what we consistently saw over and
I mean the guys that come to us
when a guy is coming to us think about
this really right they're willing to
spend 200 in cash out of pocket per
month they're willing to buy a random
box from a company off Facebook prick
their finger then tell a doctor for 30
minutes who they've never met
my dick doesn't work my wife hates me I
feel like less of a man and then get
this medication and inject themselves
all of which are absolutely crazy it's
because they've got to probably be in a
really difficult place in their life and
they're in a lot of pain yeah it um it
reminds me a lot of uh
the identity switch so like if you read
James clear's Atomic habits you know he
talks a lot about like uh one of the
best ways to change your habits is be
like uh
I don't drink and then all of a sudden
you like stop drinking less right like
or you start drinking less or whatever
and so this is like how do you change
your identity like at some point you
have to make the decision like I I want
to change because I hit the rock bottom
and then that leads to the action uh
change which is um which is fascinating
if somebody comes today
what can they actually do with you all
like what do you provide from a product
standpoint that uh you would say like
the most popular things that the uh the
clients and and the people in the
community are actually doing
I mean the first thing right is most
people
and this goes to an endemic problem that
we probably have in our country with the
medical system
they've been searching for answers for
why they feel like this for five ten
years so you first need a way to
objectively obsess
what's going on with their body so first
and foremost they come to us we look at
their hormones they do it from the
comfort of their home and we say based
upon your hormones this is what's
happening with your body
then we also give them an outlet to tell
their Physicians that something is
legitimately what is wrong with you and
more important like where do you want to
go in life because people want to go
different places and that means we have
a very different set of actions that we
want them to do might just be Lifestyle
Changes might be taking a medication
might be they want to live longer we
started selling longevity medications
and we put together longevity plans and
then we basically have you tested again
because we want to make sure
everything's safe and then we give you
medications now but the most important
thing is once I give you a medication
going back to the fact that everyone's
different my body all of a sudden hated
coffee and then I started loving coffee
again
you have to try a medication because you
were running an experiment on yourself
and then you've got to figure out the
way it makes you feel there's this
really deep qualitative component but
most people don't know what to do with
that qualitative component and so you've
got to work with a trained professional
that's been doing this for 10 15 20
years that can say oh that feeling
you're experiencing means it's either
working it's not working and if it's not
working let's try a different medication
because different medications make
people feel different or if it is
working maybe you can feel even a little
bit better let's think about what that
looks like you've got to give titrate
the medication change the medication you
got to re-measure their biomarkers and
you've got to see how your body's
beginning to react and then you've got
to do that every 90 days until what they
call you fine-tune or you dial in what
your actual protocol is and then more
importantly you've got to continue
having that conversation with a
physician because every 90 years 90 days
or 180 days your body is going to change
again or maybe you want to do something
different perfect example I mean how
many people ran this New York City
marathon we had so many guys coming to
us saying hey I'm going to be training
for the mayor Marathon what are other
things that I could be doing in addition
to the testosterone to make sure that I
prepare my body for it should I be
increasing my dosage should I be taking
glutathione alongside of it and so we
help consult on those things as well too
and make sure we create these very
bespoke plans for guys so that's really
it's when you say a product it is a
individualized product for the
individual based upon what they want in
their life at that point
I talk about
are we headed towards a world where uh
people talk about the singularity Tech
and the body will like or humans will
merge right
are we getting there from like a
um medicine or a uh
exogenous uh materials and the human
body like people think of the
singularity as like put a chip in your
brain yep
what you're really talking about is like
this like optimization is that like a
version of it where majority of humans
at some point
the cost structures will get there
access will get there and like humans
will be able to operate as optimized as
possible because of this stuff let me
ask you a question and I'll answer all
right
if I could take your soul your brain
and when you're going to die and your
body's gonna fail I could put it into
that box over there and it would run as
a computer would you do it
uh I invested in a company they try to
do this so I'm probably the worst person
to ask uh yeah I think I would do it
um
the only I think two things uh that
become a little weird are uh like the
ethical concerns right so like
technology doesn't exist so we don't
have to worry about it but like if they
could take your brain and all the
synapse connections and like put in
another body
like then that gets a little weird like
I almost would prefer to be put in a
machine and put in like another human
um it's like that's a little weird uh
but then the other thing is
for what
so like when this specific company
pitched me they're like well imagine if
you could feed like today's problems
like Albert Einstein's brain that'd be
fascinating like it would be better
would it not matter like we don't know
but like imagine if you could do it
right
um it's like that's very different than
like uh
hey you're gonna die but uh your wife is
not gonna hang out with this computer
that says it does all the things you
would do but like it's a computer you
know I gotta talk to her
I gotta get a permission slip slide yeah
I mean like it's almost like a little
bit of that but but I generally think
that uh
right now a lot of people would say no
but I think that'll change over time
maybe it's like the way I think about it
but let me ask you more of a point what
do you do it but selfishly I can put
your body or put your your on your last
leg you have one of two options you're
gonna die or I could put your soul into
this computer it's not gonna hurt by the
way yeah What's it gonna be like I don't
really know but you're gonna be in that
computer and it gives you the
possibility to continue living on
forever would you do it
and you have to decide right now
kind of feel like uh from an optionality
standpoint like yeah like let's [ __ ] it
let's do it and then like you can pull
the plug later if you need I don't know
yeah I guess
so it's interesting the the way I look
at this is I feel like I'm getting
tricked here that's like a trick
question
I think there's there is
people saying I want to integrate that
technology into my life because
it gives me another piece of information
or data or enhances my life and there is
the hey if I don't do this I may die
argument and I'll give you you know a
great great example
um
my father was a type 1 diabetic
and he was lazy and
the way dealing with diabetes
it's so hard when I say like he was a
particle physicist he discovered Florida
puddles he was absolutely brilliant but
he also didn't like doing extra work and
so he had a basically a a continuous
glucometer or CGM on one side then he
had a machine that was smart enough to
sense when that happened well it
actually wasn't a closed loop yet and he
would then press a button and it would
administer insulin right he needed that
to live
she then needed a pacemaker to live and
he had a pacemaker to live
he then needed
hip artificial hip yep throw it in right
and he's becoming a cyborg hold on his
his email address was sod Stein I swear
to you sodstein yahoo.com he's a Star
Trek junkie and so then you you start to
to ask yourself if I need these things
in order to live will I go ahead and say
yeah go ahead throw it in the bag and
I'll tell you what my stance is if I've
got a family if I enjoy my life
I am going to roll that dice every
single time and going back to that
comment about it the medical advances
that are coming around the corner you're
going to see more and more of that
happening I just read that they've
developed a technology for a guy with
ALS doesn't have to doesn't have to move
his hands because he can't they
implanted a chip in his head he's
sending texts he's going through the web
he's actually telling his wheelchair to
walk it's a [ __ ] amazing let's go yo
let's go oh why not and so when when I
say is the The Singularity here no it's
not here but I think that more and more
options will begin to present themselves
and I think that you'll see more and
more people electing to yup let's go
ahead and do it is it going to hurt me a
little bit that's fine will I be able to
live a little bit longer and actually
decide spend more time with my family
yep let's do it
I'm Gonna Leave You with a uh uh crazy
hot take that people haven't gone
through the steps but sometimes I like
to sit and think about
seven eight ten steps ahead of like how
this could play out
at some point in the future I think that
people will make the argument that the
brain computer interfaces are necessary
for everyone to ensure that the human
population's posture remains intact
what's your definition of posture
do you know like the text neck you know
how everyone's always like huddled over
their phone or over their computer
if you no longer have to have the
physical device with your hands and the
potential arthritis and all this stuff
and everything and all you can do is you
can I need to text that person think and
it texts them and you can somehow get
back what they're saying just just text
them let's use as an example and now all
of a sudden you literally can basically
return people back to just standing up
straight not being huddled over their
phone all the time but you don't think
of like how big of a deal it is but if
I've read a couple of studies where like
Physicians are like do this like a
generational problem is like people are
literally just huddled over those phones
and they pull their shoulders up and
like we're gonna have a bunch of
hunchbacks
and it's like okay now again I'm
exaggerating to some degree as to like I
don't know if people actually make that
argument but like
there is Arguments for some of these
technologies that we don't even think
about yet that people will make and I do
think it'll Usher most of them in
it's really interesting you say that
because there's a book called the
shallows right my last company was in
education technology company we help
kids become better writers
and what the book basically said is when
you used to read on p on we'll call it
like a traditional piece of paper
paperback I forgot what they're even
called God
you take your time you take time to
engage with the comments with the words
you read them and you think about them
and you can actually get into very deep
thought
the flip side of that is in today's
society we are just constantly scrolling
things and we don't actually truly get
into deep learning and understand it and
because there's more content around the
bend you hit it and you get another hit
of dopamine you're jumping on the next
thing before you've even fully processed
that and they say that children will and
this was the argument this was written
almost 10 years ago will not be able to
maintain and retain information the same
exact way that adults previously could
and because of that will have mental and
emotional problems which interestingly
is starting to play itself out whether
it's because they're not consuming
content they're on social media looking
at other people's lives but a very real
problem with I would say our young
people today right tremendous amount of
anxiety mental anguish and so I think
that whether it's the Hunchback thing in
us being hunched over it's not crazy
whether it's the fact that because of
these pollutants people have lower
testosterone and lower sperm levels and
that their epigenetic changes that are
passing on to their kids I think we
almost don't know whatever what's going
to happen but I will say this there's a
bunch of things that are probably very
not positive and it's just the way the
world is evolving and then you have to
kind of figure out what's the next
solution you're going to come slap on
that
the more we talk the more I'm like oh
we're all screwed
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or if they want to check
out uh the various products where can we
send them uh so you can get me I just
give you my email personal email is s
Alum homehealth.com I'm sure I can give
it to you can put in the show notes you
can find me on Instagram it's n m sod
Alum uh that's my handle I'm sure you
can put that in show notes as well too
those are the two easiest places to find
me name of the company is Home Health
h-o-n-ealth.com awesome thank you so
much we'll definitely do this again in
the future yeah man appreciate it this
has been great